[Musique]
le domaine natura 2000
en fait ça commence à 1 dimanche sur mon
lit en train de s'écrouler les réseaux
sociaux qu'en fait au bout d'un moment
je me retrouve face à ce sujet de brut à
face à cette vidéo est à cette petite
fille donc à aura moment là je
je me laisse un peu dépassé par mes
émotions principalement parce que cette
histoire elle me touche
moi je finis en me disant avec de façon
un peu utopiste
ben en fait c'est juste une histoire
d'argent quoi c'est juste une histoire
d'argent mais à ce moment là je ne sais
pas tout ce qui va se passer après
[Musique]
non
on a commencé les démarches pour à aura
en septembre octobre 2018 et que on a
obtenu tout obtenu en octobre 2010
ap voilà et qu'on a eu un parcours où
tout s'est fait au final mais non sans
difficultés beaucoup difficultés pour
être connecté avec l'irak avec des
personnes fiables disponibles pour être
en lien avec les familles qui elle vit
dans une zone retirer qui n'a pas accès
internet cette année là elle est chaque
jour a été indispensable pour réaliser
une tâche administrative organisationnel
et en fait il ya même un moment on s'est
dit est ce qu'on va réussir à tenir dans
ce dans ce temps voilà qui est fait qui
était d'un an et maximum qu'on n'avait
pas le choix et après il y voit là il ya
eu plein de choses qui sont passés avec
une date immuable c'est s'avisait
nettoiera reportait si on n'y arrivait
pas on reporte à l'opération à on ne
savait pas quand c'est ça
minimum un an après pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces calculs
[Musique]
la cohabitation se passe très bien c'est
une femme et une petite sophie
absolument gentille
ça se passe très bien on va passer noël
avec elle les nouvelles 1 et plein de
choses
[Musique]
aujourd'hui en fait si je trouve
important qu'on puisse exprimer et
raconter cette histoire c'est pas juste
pour montrer c'est aussi et surtout pour
dire que individuellement à partir du
moment où on sent vraiment que quelque
chose est possible même si la fenêtre
elle est toute petite
c'est qu'il ya quelque chose à faire
c'est qu'on peut aller au bout et même
si au départ avec nos moyens individuels
on sent que ça sera pas possible parce
que moi la première je connaissais rien
du tout à cette pathologie je savais pas
comment récupérer 20000 euros
mais il ya plein de choses qui se sont
alignés il ya eu plein dead j'ai eu le
message de fatima
j'ai eu après d'autres gens qui ont été
là pour nous aider pour faire des
traductions plein de choses donc
individuellement tout est vraiment
possible